(audience applauds)
- Hello, everyone. Thank you
for joining this session.
What I thought I'd do
today is walk you through
a set of examples that we
have built and deployed
across multiple Fortune 500 companies,
specifically focused
around agentic applications
which are on data science
and analytics, right?
Roughly around late last year,
we started with this thesis
on the fact that classical
AI, data science,
and gen AI are converging into agentic AI.
And then when we look at that
from that standpoint of view,
likely most of the decision engines
that have been built over the
last maybe around 15 years
will probably be reimagined
from an agentic AI standpoint of view.
And largely this is
going to be multimodal,
multi-agent systems that are capturing
many of these enterprise workflows.
So that's essentially the thesis
that we started with last year.
And over the last 12 months, or this year,
we are seeing a number of key developments
that are accelerating
that particular trend,
especially from an analytics
and data science standpoint of view.
And specifically I think five things
that started around
December last year to now
have helped accelerate
this particular process.
One probably is more on reasoning.
Today, we are able to execute
complex multi-step analysis.
So you ask a question,
then the application
is able to think through saying that here
are the five second order or third order
underlying question that
I need to investigate,
and then reason around those.
And then the second
thing that also came out
was more around agentic workflows,
which became mainstream.
I mean, if we look at last year,
probably most of the workflows
are relayed around NA10,
and those are the ones
that are going around.
Whereas now we have workflows
on the mainstream side.
And then we have domain infusion,
which is going through
knowledge graphs and ontologies,
which is kind of helping us
put not only the domain part
into the agentic application,
but also any
enterprise-specific information
that we need to plug in to these agents
from a context standpoint of view.
This combined with MCP servers and evals
is giving us very clear
deterministic performance
where the LLMs are not hallucinating,
but we are able to
drive specific questions
and specific answers that
are running through it.
And then if you look at this
from a analytic standpoint of view,
we need reasoning and
then also specifically
from a fine tuning standpoint of view
where I can ask the question
to the bigger model,
but then it triggers a
smaller fine tune model
which is answering some
of the specific things
that are necessary for that to perform.
And then you have the workflows,
the domain infusion that is there.
And then I need to combine
this with the compliance
and the security layer,
because if you look at taking
an application into production
on the enterprise side,
compliance and legal needs
to approve these agents
that are running around.
So for example, one of the
application that we have deployed
was on the healthcare side
where the reps are using it,
the medical service liaisons are using it,
and the home office is
also using the application.
And then the compliance team needs to have
configurable guardrails
which they can control
and see how the applications are doing.
This, combined with context engineering
and also the LLM ops
and the telemetry side,
is helping us drive that
performance of the agentic apps
that we are deploying at this juncture.
So today, I thought I
will just walk you guys
through four specific examples.
One is on demand customer analytics,
and many of you would've
done customer analytics
in the past.
It always takes a lot of
time for us to execute it.
But now with the agentic AI applications,
we're able to take complex questions
that are coming from home
office and then drive that
analysis end to end and then
bring it back to the table.
And all these four applications
I think are in my mind,
are kind of increasing in sophistication.
So I'm able to do the analysis.
Then in the case of a
marketing standpoint of view,
you're able to generate the
right content and the response,
and then execute it from a CRM side.
And then segmentation is something
that we are using from a
marketing analytics side.
And then also forecasting
probably is the most nuanced
because there are multiple
stakeholders that are involved.
Everybody has an opinion on
what the forecast needs to be
or what are some of the
drivers that are driving it.
So those, the four examples I
thought would be interesting
to share with you guys.
All of these are currently deployed
in multiple Fortune 500 companies.
They are in production at this juncture,
and they're driving impact.
So the first one that I would
like to walk you guys through
is on customer analytics.
And, so in this case you can
see that I've asked a question
and then the application
is thinking through
what are the different steps
that I need to execute.
So this includes, is this a question
that I can actually
answer that is approved,
or maybe I'm not allowed
to answer this question?
It thinks through that.
If there's secondary steps,
it's going through that,
and then generates a summary
from that standpoint of view.
If you look back two years back,
the best ChatGPT video generating,
well, like a Python chart at best,
but in this case, now
we are able to provide
full scale visualization.
And then it's also integrated
into the CRM system
at this point.
So you have the agentic AI application
which the reps can access
directly from Salesforce
or in this case Veeva
on the healthcare side.
And they're able to interact
with those applications.
And similarly, when we
look at medical reps
that are accessing it, they're
combining both structured
and unstructured data together
and driving those insights.
So it's not just structured data,
but you can also access unstructured data,
which is sitting in a
different application,
and then drive the analysis
completely on this case.
So that's kind of where we are looking at
from a on-demand customer
analytics standpoint of view.
This is something that we have
deployed not only on the US
but also in APAC like
Japan and other areas
where you have language that
needs to be taken into account.
Because on the Japan side,
the context is a little bit different.
The reps behave a little bit differently.
The home office behaves
a little bit differently.
In fact, one of the challenges that we had
is that Japanese language is quite formal
when an LLM answers a question.
It is not kind of what they're used to it.
So you are to take that
into the consideration.
At the same time, the
compliance departments
needs to be able to look
at all the questions
everybody is asking.
So the last six to nine months,
I think close to 100,000
questions have been asked
by reps and medical reps and home office.
They need to be able to look
into what are the answers
that are coming out, trace
answers on an ongoing basis,
and see if there are any
issues that we need to monitor.
That's one of the
application that we are able
to deploy into production.
The second one that's interesting is
more on marketing standpoint of view.
So this has been deployed
with a very large
real estate company.
I think they're the second
largest or the third largest
real estate company in the US.
And the way they're using it is they scan
all the new information that is happening
at any given point in time.
And then they go back and
see what are the new leads
that are able to generate.
If you're looking at it from
a marketing standpoint of view
in the past, any context
enrichment that is being done,
that has always been a separate
process that has been done.
So now you're able to identify the lead,
take that particular information,
and then check it with Apollo or Zoominfo,
depending upon what they're using,
and then enrich that context
for that application.
And then take those leads,
and you are able to take
your existing emails
that you might have sent.
So if there is an MD or
someone who has written
a lot of emails, the agent
is able to learn that context
on what is the style in which
that emails are being written,
and then draft the appropriate response.
In this case, they're not
just automated emails,
but you are continuously
learning based on what
the lead is doing, enrich
more context around it,
and then write the right response,
including images or text
that is going to them, right?
So that improves the
response rate quite a bit.
So in this case, the real
estate company that is using it,
they're able to scale up the
total number of marketing leads
that they're generating,
enrich them on a daily basis,
and then send those responses
pretty at scale at this juncture.
Now, if we shift this a
little bit from a marketing
to segmentation, which most
marketing analytics company,
marketing analytics divisions look at.
So this is a case where we are able to run
a full segmentation end-to-end,
depending upon what the questions are.
So this can be a question
around what is the,
based on latest
information that is coming,
and let's say your sales are down
or there's a new segment that
you believe that is coming up
based on demographics, you're able to look
into a planning engine
which looks at all the data
that's coming in, create new personas,
reason through those personas,
and look into what are some of the drivers
that might be affecting that
particular demographic segment
and what are the product
lines that are resonating
with that segment, and
complete this entire process.
So we kind of designed
this segmentation workflow
which captures how a data
analyst or a data scientist
does segmentation using multiple models,
and then trigger that from
an agent standpoint of view
and refresh the segmentation
on an ongoing basis.
So in the past, if you look at it,
it used to be probably a
three or four-member team
or a five-member team which does this work
or three or four months
on an ongoing basis.
And that always used to be a lot of work.
You cannot run multiple
segmentation personas
at any given point in time.
And the latency to do it has
been large at this juncture.
Now that entire workflow
of the segmentation
can be executed within a day or two
across multiple datasets.
The datasets can be in your
main data warehouse in AWS
and also across CRM and other elements.
And then we are able to bring
all that context together
and then drive the full
segmentation exercise.
A slightly more complex
engine is forecasting.
So in this case, forecasting,
let's say tomorrow is a
particular event that has happened
from a pricing standpoint of view,
or some product has a stockout scenario.
Then I need to review how the
forecast is from last quarter
that somebody might have done,
look at the actuals that are going in.
And then also there is a lot of opinions
when we do forecasting
in an ongoing basis.
So I want to go back and see
if a particular assumption
is still accurate or not accurate.
If it is not accurate,
somebody might want to smoothen
that particular aspect.
So that entire aspect is now
encoded into the workflow.
This is where we are looking
at from a domain infusion
standpoint of view where a
knowledge graph is capturing
all the steps that today a
forecasting team is performing.
And then take that context
and then plug that into the system.
In this particular scenario,
if the business has a
question tomorrow around
how would my forecast change
next quarter or next month
because of a disruption
or a particular activity
that has happened, we are
able to run that scenario
end to end at this juncture,
look at the risks and the
opportunities that are there,
and how that would affect the performance
for a given product or a business line.
And this is being done with
human in the loop, right?
So the team is able to supervise
what are the different
algorithms that are running
from an agentic standpoint of view
and also adjust those
across the different steps
that are happening, right?
So this gives complete control
and transparency to the teams
which are doing forecasting.
And in my mind at least,
forecasting is probably
the most nuanced and most opinionated
if you're doing marketing analytics,
because business has an opinion,
the data scientist has an opinion,
and operations gather an opinion.
And all of this needs to be tallied again
next quarter, next month
on an ongoing basis.
So that, these are couple of reasons
why I believe that
analytics and data science
is at an inflection point
from an agentic AI standpoint of view.
Because if you look at all
analytics that we have done,
and I've been in the industry
for I think 20 years now,
pre-2010, we used to do
all of the analysis in SAS.
Most of the work is logistic regression
or linear regression.
And I would say the first
inflection point was around 2011
or 2012 when the first big
data clusters came into play
where we had access to much larger data.
And then probably around
2016, 2017 is when the cloud
and the ML side took off.
So I think probably in the next few years
is where we can re-look at
all the (indistinct) engines
that have been created
over the last 15, 20 years,
which will be redone from
agentic AI standpoint of view.
So it's not just me saying
it, but what we did is,
in the last two months, we
asked Forrester to run a survey
across roughly 400 different
analytics organizations.
And primarily the survey
respondents are all decision makers
or they're running the
particular analytics departments.
And overwhelmingly most of
them are basically saying that,
you know, they expect
human-in-the-loop agents
to be coming online over the next year
and then probably many
of them also getting
to autonomous levels
in the next 24 months.
So this is across 400
different organizations
on what they expect to happen
in the next one to two years.
And then they're also
expecting agentic analytics
to play a significant role
in the next two years.
Because if you look at
it, they're expecting
agentic analytics to automate
many of the routine analytics
that the departments are doing today.
And they're also expecting
many of these core workflows
to be able to generate
insights at a much faster pace.
Like roughly half of
them are basically saying
that the speed in time
to get those insights
should be like half the
time what it takes today.
And probably it should roughly cost half
of what it costs us today to do analytics.
So that's a significant chunk of people
that are working on this.
And one of the questions
I would ask the audience,
I would leave this with this question,
is that if every big tech organization
is saying that they're
going to have a mid-level
software developer or a
junior software developer
to come online in the next 12 months,
and the question that I'm
asking is that how long
it would be before you have
fully functioning AI analysts
which are doing analytics at scale?
My guess is probably
another two or three years.
I would say next two years
is going to be mostly
human-in-the-loop systems,
like the ones that you guys
have seen, whether it's
segmentation or forecasting.
I would say most of the
analytics that we are doing
can be redone using
human-in-the-loop systems.
And then as we get more
comfortable with these systems,
I would expect them to kind
of be more and more autonomous
where you can say that,
okay, there's a system
that's running pricing
on an ongoing basis.
You'll have an analyst
who is monitoring it
maybe once every two days or three days
and see if it is everything is going fine.
But then they're largely
kind of running that function
on an ongoing basis.
And that's broadly what we are expecting
on how analytics is going to change
and data science is going
to change over the next
maybe four or five years.
So those are a couple of
things I wanted to share today.
If there are any questions,
I'm happy to answer
on how we have developed and deployed
some of these analytic
systems over the last year.